Welcome back!
Hello!
Hi, I'm Mikana Jones.
Howdy.
Howdy... y'all.
Welcome... to...
Which is probably... possibly... I don't know.
Probably the last Indiana Jones stream.
Vodgang...
Don't...
If I'm...
Vodgang, tell me if I'm correct or not.
Vodgang checking in.
You're literally here, what are you talking about?
You can do it in about 6 hours.
Okay.
I think I can do that.
Oh my god.
Did you hear my tummy?
It went...
Howdy minky, howdy runny-chan, thanks for 4 months!
Thank you!
Thanks for the 5 gifts, dude!
Howdy-dee megadoodoo.
Trying to go until I finish, basically.
As much as I love the game...
It's one of those, you know, I'm ready to start a new series.
Kind of dealio.
So...
Kind of dealio, I'm ready to move on!
What?
It's been like 2 months of this game, I feel.
Jerry, thank you for the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
Mr. Albeezy, welcome back!
Hello, hello, hello.
VOD viewer here.
This is important.
Don't forget to...
Forget to what?
Weapon!
Mr. Albeezy, thank you for the 10 gifted!
Apparently, hand kill is going to be in Fortnite.
When will Indiana Jones be in Fortnite?
I wonder.
But no, I've been having so much fun with this game, so...
I am sad to finish it, but...
I'm also just excited to see how it ends, honestly.
Gosh, what happened last time?
We fought a giant.
I do remember that.
Wait, he was?
Indiana Jones was in Fortnite!
Twice!
They added Indy ages ago!
Won't leave the room.
Cat.
Yeah, my cat!
She is... Pauses in here.
Which means she will probably start screaming at me in about 20 minutes.
We'll see.
What time is it?
Okay.
Let's... Countdown.
Fake fan, SMH.
Well, I guess you could say I am a fake fan of Fortnite.
That is true.
I am maybe a fake fan of Fortnite.
Don't spoil the final boss.
I don't know anything!
I don't even know who is still playing this game.
Anymore.
It's me.
I'm the only one still playing this game, maybe.
I meant I became a hag today.
It would mean a lot if I could get a happy birthday from my Kamiyoshi!
I've been looking forward to it.
Of course, Nexie!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Nexie hag!
You finished it a couple of days ago.
You liked it?
Okay, maybe I'll like it too then.
Good morning!
Good morning, good morning, Miss Koiu!
Bionic Hippo, welcome back!
Alright.
I heard Paws chirp.
No you didn't!
No you didn't.
I see her still laying in her bed.
She is still laying in her bed.
I thought though recently... She really loves to look out the window, right?
I think... I think I'm gonna have to get her one of those...
Beds that...
Stick to the window.
Who's Paws?
My cat!
That's my cat.
But I'm afraid of those.
Because I'm afraid that they will fall, you know?
The balcony... Is that what it's called?
So hyped to see Minto together with Indy.
Yeah, we're right together.
We got the same hat and everything.
I got my little whip.
You know.
Hold on.
Sorry, I got...
I think I got food stuck in my throat.
Now...
You got your whip and your nae nae?
I got my whip.
I got my nae nae.
Whip.
Alright.
What happened last time?
We had... Okay, actually I do remember.
Thank you.
I remember.
Hold on.
Not you.
We were going to do this...
Maybe the study in fear?
Whatever is that one that I'm pointing to.
That must be the study in fear.
Wasn't I going to go do that real quick and then we were going to continue the actual adventure?
Or was it the lost... No, not lost.
I was down here because I was going to do that.
And then...
The blessed pearl.
Do you guys say blessed or blessed?
I think I say either one.
Whatever I feel like.
The blessed pearl is the actual adventure.
So we were going to just go do this one so we could get some money, money, baby.
And then...
This one?
What was this one?
Oh, the girl in the cave.
She helped the demon and got a golden fishing hook.
Depends on the context.
Depends on if I want to be fun.
Blessed for D&D RP.
Blessed for normal.
If I'm old timey, blessed.
I got it.
Study and fear is a nice quest.
Is it really?
Maybe we will do it then.
I don't really have a time limit or anything today.
I just, you know...
Are you not coming with?
Wait, where...
OK.
Bye bye.
God, she's so fast.
What?
What hamatat?
That's what we're gonna go do.
Yeah, I know.
We're going.
Yeah, we can just go this way.
So we found the big, big temple.
And we went inside and I parkoured and I punched a snake.
And...
We fought a giant.
We solved a puzzle.
And now we're on the...
We're on the river.
Why is the music so spooky?
Shut up Xbox.
Xbox.
Why is the music so scary?
Oh, wrong way, wrong way.
Yeah, we're down, down, down by the river.
I actually got my new PC, right?
And I was considering playing the game on my new PC.
Oh, it must be over there.
But I have some issues, so...
I have some issues with some of my fans.
So I had to get a new part.
So basically, I kinda went, I don't know, I kinda went a little fancy.
With lights and stuff.
And I accidentally got some fans that are a little fancier than I wanted.
But that's okay because I like them.
Can I get up in there?
I think so.
But...
But I think they're not getting enough power.
What's this music?
I'm scared.
I feel like I'm getting discovered.
You think we can go in there?
Or should I go...
A little bit more.
Let's go a little bit more.
No, it's not.
It's...
Basically...
I didn't...
I didn't get the...it's not a controller.
I don't remember what it's called.
Oh, nice.
Here we go.
Okay, dock the boat.
I don't remember.
Sorry guys, I'm actually trying to pilot and find this place while also explaining.
What?
What are you talking about?
Okay, I also don't remember how to fight.
Okay, I remember how to fight.
She is...Gina is so confusing.
She cracks me up though.
Wait, they'll shoot us?
Is that what you just said?
Devil?
A devil.
That which is predestined.
But it's not for this reason, evil.
Okay, Andy.
Are there people here?
I'm scared.
I thought I heard someone whistling.
Gina.
Gina, I'm scared.
I don't want to get exploded.
Or shot.
Fan here.
I'm sorry, I have issues.
I'll go to therapy.
Oh my god.
Investigate the temple grounds.
Gina.
Gina, please.
Gina, I need some moral support.
I need a woman's touch.
She's really just sitting here.
Okay, fine.
Whatever.
What if there are snakes?
Okay, I'm investigating.
Yeah.
Dead, I hope.
Yeah, so true.
So true.
What am I doing?
Investigate the temple grounds.
Okay.
In here?
What else is around here?
A little water bottle.
A gun?
I will gladly acquire.
So true, bestie.
Come here.
That, I think, is a peacock.
My neighbor used to have peacocks.
I'm treasuring them.
Alright, let's go in.
How do I get out once I go in?
That's for future Indy to worry about.
Oh gosh, why am I so scared all of a sudden of this game?
We're in the vault?
Okay.
Wow, you don't want a picture of this?
Not interesting enough for you, Indiana Jones?
Okay.
Maybe they got scared.
Maybe they got scared of something.
Or they got sucked in.
Here we go!
I
mean, yes, shoot, but...oh shoot.
No, why?
You're just whistling.
Your friends are dead and you're whistling?
Whistling?
The shoulder pad is so good.
How do I drop this gun?
Hold on, crouch.
There we go.
Whistle, whistle, whistle, whistle, whistle.
Maybe it wasn't me.
Maybe I was the one whistling.
Oh my god.
Oh, okay.
I like her pants.
Yeah.
Annika.
Annika Lund.
Yeah.
That's awkward.
You're our student?
Uh oh.
You're our student and you literally use explosives?
Okay.
She's gonna betray us, isn't she?
I'm gonna have to punch a woman.
Look at her.
She already looks like she's contemplating how to betray me.
Give me your fire.
There we go.
Alright, set her on fire.
Literally, she does not give anything.
She does not care at all about those guys that died.
I'm... you... you!
No!
She has the nerve to say... oh man.
She has the nerve to say that when she used explosives to get in here in the first place.
She's like, I'm innocent.
I'm an innocent person whistling.
I would never betray you, Dr. Jones.
Resting betrayer face.
She's got them... she's got them... what's it called?
Them seppuku eyes.
Sanpaku eyes.
She was... she's...
The whistle of a betrayer.
She's like, whistle, whistle.
I'm an innocent girl.
Sudoku eyes.
What did I just open?
Oh, what the hell is that?
Give it to me.
Oh.
What?
This girl's stupid.
We RBFers don't claim it.
What if she's good?
I'm guessing Anika is the student that passed with a C-.
She was busy...
It's not a key.
Actually, I think you're right.
What do I... oh, do I have to make them align?
Where's this... wait.
Do I make them align?
Yeah, I know.
Yeah, I will.
What legend?
True.
Okay, Anika, I know you want out.
She did not seem worried at all about being able to get out of here or not.
She truly was just like...
What the hell?
What is all this?
Oh, now she's sighing.
Okay, now you're impatient?
Impatient!
Is this game good, Mint?
Also, why is Meido Minto so fun to say?
I think it's fun.
I think if you like Indiana Jones, you will enjoy it.
If you're an Indiana Joey...
What'd she say?
I know there is.
A lever?
Wait, a lever where?
Stop the cogwheels.
Gamer pain!
Am I doing it?
Oh, what?
Okay, hold on.
Let's try over here.
We'll wait.
He needs to kill people!
Did we get it?
It's quiet now.
It's nice and quiet.
Another key.
Hmm.
Are we?
Yank!
Oh!
I'm breaking things.
They died, but they're go... Oh, I needed that to move it!
I'm such a smarty pants, aren't I?
Oh, and then... How do I switch to the other one?
I got my bread.
Where is the other cross?
This circle.
The great circle!
Frosty, thanks for 7 months!
I don't like nachos either, but it's a colossal red flag.
You are my student!
Annika!
How do you whistle like that?
How do you whistle without...
How do you whistle without doing...
I can take a picture of her?
Ooh, hot mama!
I'm taking a picture of...
Ahem, to you!
Gosh, she's so...
Okay.
No, we want the...
I was just holding it.
The circle.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh no, that didn't work at all.
Nevermind.
How do I get the... Wait.
Am I stupid?
The cross.
How do I get the middle?
Wait.
Okay, we gotta... Oh, we just gotta time it to this one then.
I'm smart.
Don't worry guys.
I've got a good...
I've got a brain.
It works!
Yeah, I'm a genius!
Indiana U genius.
Yeah, we just crouch.
I wish we had our...
I love the way she runs.
It's so funny.
Indiana U genius.
I think there's any little artifacts.
That doesn't look good.
Oh my god.
Ah!
She's trying to kill me.
She's trying to kill me for real.
Oh my god.
That spooked me.
That spooked the heck out of me.
Oh, I can't... Okay.
Yeah, no shit!
Oh my god!
She's worse than Gina!
I don't think we should have passed her.
I think...
I think she shouldn't have passed the class.
Anika, I'm taking back your degree.
Stop whistling on the job please.
Oh, you're gonna drive me crazy.
I thought I was so lucky to be...
To be stuck in here with such a beautiful lady, but...
Why is there gamer paint on this?
There's nowhere to go.
I used to be a big fan of Mint.
But after watching her for longer, I'm now a whole air conditioner.
That's a good one.
Who's saying she passed?
Indy clearly doesn't remember.
True.
Wait, shouldn't you be doing the spooking here?
I don't haunt this place.
Why were you searching for this anyway?
True.
She's giving... She's serving face or something.
Girly?
I'm just looking around.
I like the...
I don't... Indy...
Gamers never look up except when it's literally a death trap.
Indy, I don't think we should open this.
Indiana Jones.
The wall, the ceiling is Swiss cheese.
Look, that's gonna literally lower.
Okay, hold on.
We gotta look at our escape route.
We gotta look for an escape route before we do this, right?
Something.
Maybe I can...
Okay.
I'm prepared to die.
I've made my amends.
What are you looking at?
I don't see anything.
I'm gonna get on top.
Just kidding.
Okay.
I don't wanna get on top anymore.
I don't... What do you mean this... Okay, hold on.
We are parkouring.
What could be a way to open this?
The light hits the mushroom.
Something here, yeah.
Break dancing on the sarcophagus.
Oh, I see it.
I did it.
I found it.
Perfect.
Not very secure, but it took me a second to find it.
Okay.
I saved.
I like the locks.
They are very cute, right?
Just got in.
What did I miss?
Not much, actually.
We just met this lady.
She is one of our old students, apparently.
It's empty.
Empty.
Your soul died.
This looks breakable, right?
Yeah!
This is...
Break it!
Break it with your fist!
Break it with...
This!
Break it with this!
I messed up.
Oh god!
It's really filling up fast.
Why is it so steamy?
Wait!
This way!
Oh my god.
No, there is no way we are going to make it.
I'm trapped.
Wait, can I swim down?
There we go.
Wait, how do I...
X to something.
Lift!
We are not dying today, baby!
Oh, they are Anika, baby.
Oh my god.
Why would I want to drop down?
Sayonara!
Why would I want to do that?
Hello?
Indiana Jones.
Get back up there.
No, Indy.
Indy, get back up there.
What am I
doing?
Oh, it's just a ketchup red.
We are continuing...
Oh, this way.
There she is.
Oh, she didn't betray us.
She didn't betray us.
What if I miss?
She has a white T-shirt on, right?
Alright.
We are still...
That would have been unfortunate.
Anika, you are freaking me out.
That?
That looks like a door?
Retro.
Okay.
She doesn't have much worldly experience, I'm afraid.
She is young and trusts so easily.
Yeah, she is very trusting.
She is maybe a little gullible.
Okay, we gotta go over up here.
What's in...
A secret found!
We got...
Beautiful.
We got a little Among Us.
I probably could have lowered a little bit, but...
I took a chance.
Nice.
Wait, how do I lower...
There we go.
What's on the other side?
Oh, sorry, Endy.
How do you...oh.
I can't get up here.
She is kind of funny.
I gotta take a...
Oh, little girl.
Come on.
Come on, little girl.
My cat went out of the room.
Hold on.
Okie dokie.
What am I taking a picture of?
Oh, the watermelon.
Where we almost died.
Snap.
Why did they build any of this, Endy?
I have many questions.
Wait, are we trying to pull her up or...
You gotta come over here, Annika.
Ok, and...
What's this?
Nothing, it appears.
What am I...
Where is...is there an entrance?
It looked like I needed to come over here, though.
I don't think...this is down into the river where we just came from, so definitely not that.
What?
Help Annika?
Do I help her out first?
Oh, ok.
Yeah, I do.
Come on up.
Oh,
there was a thing right here.
Oh, ok.
Go!
Yeah, it is the Temple of Doom outfit.
TV table tray, thanks for the cat.
Just figured out how to send this 9 months later.
Thanks Boobies!
This is definitely it.
Having a look around.
Oh, more of these guys.
They are so cute.
What am I hearing?
Oh, this thing.
Ok.
Yes!
Take!
What do you mean not that?
What are you talking about, Indy?
I literally did it.
We have to bring water to this one.
And this one.
Water, water.
Is this like the previous puzzle?
We did one last time where I had to redirect a bunch of water.
Minky?
Oh, he said not bad.
Ah,
the demon giant.
So mean.
Once we find the horrible ugly guy, we can leave.
Yeah, you jump over that.
Oh I see the blood.
Yeah, I got it.
Oh, it's disgusting.
Oh gosh, nasty.
Ok, now this one should be spin, spin, spinning.
Yes indeedy.
Wait, I had it good actually.
Yeah?
Oh!
How do I...
What do you want me to do?
Oh, it was a bird, not a...
Destroy the nest!
Thanks for two vents.
Do you want me to parkour over there?
There's no way.
How do you want me to get that bird?
It was not a minky.
Do a flip.
I could very well do that.
Ok, I got up to this ledge.
Maybe right this here?
No.
Oh, no, no, no.
This ledge?
Oh, so close, so close.
So close.
Oh my god.
I don't think this is how you are supposed to do it, but...
This is how we are going to do it.
Anika, get on my shoulders.
Come on.
Come on!
I don't see a demon giant, but a freaky baby.
Oh,
it does both of them.
Interesting.
Which actually, this...
Oh wait, but the one that we have...
Oh, this one.
I forgot it does the middle.
Oh wait, why did this...
Ok.
Oh, that's not what I expected.
That did it, baby.
Now you...
I'm such a genius.
Wait, but this one will do the two of them.
Or this one will do two of them, right?
Ok?
Ok, ok.
And then what did this one do?
Oh, just the middle two.
I think we gotta...
Oh, my bad.
Oh, now it's all out of sync.
But I think we gotta time it to the...
to the outside one.
We gotta time...
Is it this one?
There we go.
Still got it.
Yeah, I do.
Is that supposed...
Circle key.
What?
I'm surprised all of this wood still works.
You know what I mean?
Like it's...
The fact that it's not rotted and like everything is kind of crazy.
Oh, wow!
That's kind of insane!
Get out of my shot!
You found it?
Excuse me, ma'am?
Whoa...
Oh, I'll take that.
That looks like that's probably mine.
Annika?
Annika, you better not put that in your pocket.
Thank you for the super chat, Okami!
Appreciate it.
Whatcha got there?
Ah,
a duck.
Oh.
Watching this whole arena reminded me that when I discovered VTubers, I thought that backseating meant doing just that.
And I was having a chat to make sure I'm not kicking my teeth.
Wait, doing what?
Yeah, yeah.
I agree.
Why does she look at me like that?
She's moonwalking.
Oh, he will.
What?
She's not going to betray me!
Maybe I'm naive for trusting her.
Ancient idol is an obtuse way of saying ghost...
What are you...
Yep.
Why is it a cutscene?
Fool me once!
Oh no.
Mufasa, I mean, Asgore, help me!
Remembered me even.
I might have been working for you.
Class dismissed.
Professor Jones.
Long live the king!
Oh come on!
Wait.
I caught you, bitch!
No, I'm Indiana Jones!
I thought backseating meant just watching and not typing.
Oh no, that's such a sad experience.
Dusty dog.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Oh, there we go.
For some reason I thought it was telling me to...
light a lighter.
Alternatively, I'm done saving you.
Watch.
We're going to!
We're going to leave and we're going to find her impaled by something.
It's gonna happen.
We're gonna leave the temple and she will be...
dead, donezo, gone, gone, impaled by...
something, somewhere.
You know?
The lurkers rise up.
Lurkers!
Did I do that?
Oops.
Dummy Annika.
There it is.
Is that her?
Oh
my...
Damn!
Long live the king, Indiana Jones.
Wait.
Before I attempt that as well...
This is where I came from.
I'm trying to get my bearings.
A little bit.
Wait, that's not where I came from, is it?
Sorry.
I thought I just heard whispering.
It isn't.
Yeah, we came from a different pit.
Like over here, right?
Sorry, it's a little...
We came from here.
Way to manifest her demise.
What can I say?
Now we're all by ourselves and it's scary.
Okay, this is where we came from.
Okay, this is out of the door.
Look at this!
Actually, I'm such an idiot.
How did I not notice?
How did I not notice that this would have been...
Oopsie.
Donnie, welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Okay.
So she went this way.
We're following her steps.
Right before her death.
And then she went this way.
And then... squash!
But what's down here?
So, oh, this is obviously where we need to go since we...
Well, I'm assuming.
Well...
No, I do hear voices!
I do hear voices!
They thought it was a supernatural being!
You guys hear him too, right?
The voices, the voices.
I'm so close now.
Everyone who's underestimated me will see.
Yeah.
Oof.
So if I...
Donnie, thanks for the 10 gift, I appreciate it!
Bro, we're dealing with demons, right?
We have...
We have giants, we have demons, what else?
I don't want to open the door, I'm scared.
They all whistle.
That's how you know.
Let's open it.
It pulverized her into...
There's literally nothing but a hand.
Wait, if I go through that though, won't I also become literally just a hand?
Should we try it?
I think it saved.
Now I have to deal with bozos!
No, I just wanted to get out of here peacefully!
Oh man.
No.
Bless you.
It's Luigi's mansion.
What do I do?
Is that the exit right there?
Oh my god.
I checked out, buddy.
What about the other path?
You know what?
Yeah, let's go check that out.
I guess this is disarmed.
Time to rip those bozos.
RIP those bozos.
Watch, this probably just leads to a little...
Oh, I thought it was going to lead to a little...
Oh, what's this?
A little among us.
I see no trap.
Oh, but I see...
There... Wait.
No, this is where we came in.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is where we were trapped before.
And then... But this is...
So it's just a...
It's just a big old circle?
We looped.
Oh, interesting.
What's this way though?
Oh, this is... Duh.
This is where I just came from.
The great circle.
So I do have to go to them.
Okay.
Stinky.
You think I could just make a run for it?
Gotta deal with the Mario brothers.
This is probably fine.
I remember how to fight and I remember how to block.
I think we're okay.
Can you loot her...
Keepsake?
Gosh.
Maybe I ate her.
That's so insane.
Excuse
you.
There's plenty of room.
You could've...
I'm waiting for him to go back to that door.
When they're both looking around.
Use the force.
The guys were saying they took her to a doctor.
Is that what they said?
Okay.
Alright.
Here I go.
I hope there's no one else.
Good, they're weak.
Peaceful.
God, scared me.
How do I use this again?
Like so.
I remember.
Nice.
Alrighty.
Stealth optional.
So true.
And there should be no one else around, right?
Right.
This is the issue that I said was for future Indy.
How do we get out?
Oh, I hear whistling.
Shoot.
They didn't hear the gunshots?
Crazy.
I see no gamer tape.
Oh.
Oh my God.
All I did was jump.
It's your friends.
I can't get out.
Please.
Can you help me?
I'm stuck.
How do I get out?
Oh my God.
Oh shit.
What the hell?
Oh, they jumped in.
They jumped in.
I think.
I'm gonna whip them.
Do you think he's in here?
Maybe he'll show me how to get out.
Oh my God.
What?
That's how you got out?
He really did show me.
How did he do that?
He's the best.
You need to buy air hike.
I hate this.
We're crossing the streams.
Ok, I'm gonna try.
Oh my God!
Run!
Gina, start the boat!
Gina, start the boat.
Gina!
Gina, you left me, you bitch!
They won't chase after me, right?
I'm safe.
Anyway...
Gina, I have a lot of words for you.
Betrayal after betrayal.
Why did she leave me?
Gina!
Oh my God.
Well, we got out.
Easy peasy.
Mangosteen.
I've never tried that before.
Ok, where are we?
Ok, we have to go all the way...
A place where we can get a new boat.
Maybe.
Stomp, stomp, stomp, stomp, stomp, stomp.
It's gonna be a...
A bit of a...
If you consider lots of the appeal of Indy is him bumbling his way into and then through situations, then this is the perfect playthrough.
That's what I'm saying!
I literally did exactly what Indiana...
Jones would've.
Gina?
What the hell are you doing all the way over here?
Gina!
Why
are you at the treehouse?
Oh my God.
Why are you here?
Gina, let me in.
Gina, Gina, Gina, Gina.
Oh God, I'm under the boat.
Gina, let me up.
Hello.
Where have you been?
She's not even talking to me.
She's giving me the silent treatment.
Come on, Gina.
Let's go home.
She won't talk to me.
She has nothing to say.
This is the first time I think I've ever heard her shut up.
Quite honestly.
Am I going the right way?
Yep.
She knows you cheated.
I didn't cheat.
Oh, okay.
I can't pilot the boat and have the boat...
Why is she looking at me like that?
Like I did you wrong.
I didn't do you dirty, girl.
You left me.
This way.
I think she's supposed to be talking.
Guys, we might have broken the game.
This is the perfect bug.
It gets Gina to shut up.
Yeah.
Nice.
Triple A game.
You like Gina?
She's not bad.
She could be worse.
I kid, mostly.
But it's fun to make fun of her.
Gina really doesn't care about me, though.
She really doesn't.
Okay, right there.
Gina?
I think we're stuck.
Oh.
It actually won't let me... Wait, there we go.
Hold on.
Maybe if I go directly in?
There we go.
That was weird.
Okay.
And our little dock is right there.
Maybe I was too close to a corner or something.
Gina, you good?
Let me try talking to her again.
Gina, speak to me!
I thought... Oh no!
She's been impaled!
Maybe Gina was never really real.
Okay.
Hello?
Who am I talking to?
Oh, okay.
We did it.
I found it.
Oh.
She's a venom, Annika.
Okay, you're welcome!
Alright.
Yippee!
Study and fear completed.
Now we can move on to...
The Blessed Pearl.
Let's go.
Let's leave this area.
Gina!
I haven't heard your voice in ages!
Okay, secret armory...
Not Tong Dan Cai.
I don't remember which one is the closest.
Maybe this one.
I don't know.
Punished Annika.
A student deprived of her degree.
Let's see this one.
Where are we?
We are... Oh!
Not bad, actually.
Wat Matat.
Oh wait, maybe... I thought it was all the way up here in the corner.
Nevermind, it's right here in the middle.
Let's go to his hut.
Okay.
Let's go.
Alright, right over here.
Not very far at all, actually.
Like, right here?
So we dock here?
I guess.
Oh, right here!
I guess we never docked here before.
Okay.
We made it!
There's definitely monkeys in there.
But this place, I remember it was crawling with guys.
Yeah, you and me too, sister.
I'm scared.
I see one guy.
I'm following you.
I don't know, actually.
What are we looking for, Gina?
Do you want to give us some hints?
You do?
What?
Gina!
Look at you!
Your special eyes.
What is
it?
Regirock!
Oh my god!
Gina found it!
For real, girl!
Nevermind.
The music.
Better than Anima.
So true!
Gina, you get an A plus in my class.
Seymour, thanks for the gift!
Oh my gosh, not so loud, please!
I actually had some Regirock TikToks that I was going to show.
Oh!
Gina!
Ok, bye.
Secret entrance.
Ok, let's go.
Gina is ready to rock and roll.
Regirock and roll.
It does!
What are you trying to say, huh, Gina?
Oh, where was I looking?
Maybe we gotta kiss in front of this thing to activate it.
Is this a...
I thought it would be a timed...
Like a quick timed event.
Alright, Gina, what are you doing?
Do we have...
Do we have any of those?
A torch?
Do we have that?
A torch.
Does she want my...
My lighter?
Gina, there's like... It's really wet down here.
I don't think even a torch would work.
I'll be honest, I saw this earlier and I thought they were like a little...
Hold on.
I was saying I thought they were like the little things you blow like poison darts through, you know?
Yeah, we almost killed her.
That's ok though.
How do you know?
What about the kissing?
What's that noise?
Uh oh.
Ok.
Gina!
Let's check it out.
Yummy!
Thanks for 8 months.
If Gina won't kiss Indy, I will.
Alright, do it.
You're right.
This pre-dates the rise of Tsukutai.
People who lived here would have built their temple on top of this.
Concealing it for generations.
Tsukutai...
Maybe we could...
Where are you going?
Jones, it's the game.
But just big.
Squid...I've played these games before!
I said I've played these games before!
What's wrong?
I literally played this game.
The blessed pearl.
We have to go together.
But...
I don't want to kill you.
Ok.
She's speaking Indy language.
Yeah, the actual language is Thai.
Oh, that's not a camera.
That's not a camera either.
There we go.
Alright, game room.
I've played these games before!
Has this actually turned into a squid game?
Look, everybody's here.
Oh my god.
What should I do?
I don't remember how I played this before.
Oh, that's right.
That's right.
Hold on.
Oh god, it's really sensitive.
We have to get them all to face the same way.
I'm assuming they all have to face...
This way, right?
I don't know what I...
They all have to face this way.
I'm assuming.
Raiders.
Sorry, channel.
Thanks for the raid.
Gosh, this thing is sensitive.
Ok, that makes it face that way.
Unless they all need to face this way.
I'm not sure.
Where are we?
Thanks for the 5k.
Someone stand here.
How do I tell them to stand there?
Oh, she's doing it.
She's doing it.
Ok, nice and slow though.
What if I do this?
See, see, see.
So now, we need someone to stand here.
Ducky, thanks for the gifted.
Hey, someone.
You.
Yeah, help.
Stand here.
Like that?
Ok, ok, ok.
Wait.
Oh, but this will change it.
Ok.
Maybe here.
This one, this one, this one, this one.
Try that.
Gosh, this is going to be a process now, isn't it?
Ok, come here.
Come here, come here and you go here.
And then if I stand on it too...
Thanks.
Are you going to come with or are you just going to...
Are you just going to chill here?
With your feet in the...
I'm right here.
You don't have to yell.
I don't think he can move.
He's stuck in the rock.
He's a little stuck.
Lost temple.
Well, I...
I wasn't until you've mentioned it.
Well,
we actually have to do that.
There is a...
There is no other way in.
This is kind of creepy.
Anyone else want to jump in?
Please.
Are you ok down there?
No.
I'm scared.
What is that?
Do you think they are alive?
Messenger statue?
Oh my god.
I'm trying to...
I want to get in the middle there.
Come on in.
Not jump.
I'm not happy.
They are like...
Ten doll.
You too.
No wonder the giants died out.
Statue.
Another photo?
Statue symbol.
Nothing to say about that though.
Oh, we are still going.
I have a feeling I'm about to fight another guy.
Like another big man.
Why can't I just live a peaceful archeologist life?
Here we go.
That doesn't look good.
Is that a snake or...
What?
What the hell?
Trying to see it.
I think I parkoured over here.
What?
Leeches?
Why are they all concentrated in one area?
They are like the most...
They are fish that have not been fed in the longest time ever.
Where are they?
What the hell is this?
It's a little sensitive.
There we go.
They are following me.
It's so nasty.
And...
Nice.
Oh god, here they come.
And then I...
Good question.
Oh, there.
Everyone else would have definitely gotten in my way, huh?
I guess we are going this...
Wait, there are so many different directions I could go.
And what's up with these holes?
There are some on this side too.
I'm assuming piranhas, maybe.
Oh, hi Minty Minto.
Hope you are doing well today.
Hello.
Eric.
One Eric.
W1.
I hope you are doing well.
W2.
W1.
Get it?
What's happening?
I think they followed me over here.
But what's over there?
Hold on, there might be a little among us over that way.
It's my birthday.
Here is your card.
Turbulence, happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Turbulence.
Happy birthday.
Let's watch out for these guys.
I knew it.
Among us.
And back.
At least this one was pretty harmless to grab, I suppose.
Yeah, Indy does seem a little quiet now, doesn't he?
Oh good, it just saved.
That's kind of nice.
Indy has not been speaking much at all, has he?
I hope my game isn't bugged for real.
I think I need to jump.
No I don't.
Troy needed a break.
He's got no one to talk to.
Oh my god, I didn't think I was going to make that for a second.
I did it.
Alright, Indiana Jones on her way down.
Let's go.
This doesn't seem very safe.
Oh my god, there we go.
Hoi!
Took it a little far there, Indy.
I think.
We are almost to the bottom.
If we fell...
I think...
Ouch, we make it.
Why did I get injured?
What was that?
Anyway.
Hopefully no more giant snakes.
Where are we now?
Intersectuary.
Indy, you have nothing to say about this?
Hi, I'm Indiana Jones.
I'm going to be...
Why do I sound like...
Not Zelda, Elvis.
This looks like a trap.
That's the pearl?
Doesn't look like a pearl to me.
Maybe the game got bugged?
I think so.
Why does he look like...
What is this sussy ass face?
I gotta be a what?
It's all good now.
I think it resets after the cutscene.
But if it keeps bugging out, then I will save or quit and reset.
Uh oh.
Metatron!
It's the circle!
Megatron, rise up!
To what?
No one is telling us anything.
The great circle!
They did say don't speak his name, right?
I'm Minto.
Say my name.
That sounds like a door shutting.
Yeah, you too.
I think I'm a little tired of this.
I got it!
Oh OK.
Why was I getting hurt?
I don't know.
Why am I almost dead?
The leeches?
No way.
The pain is really coming in clutch right now.
Nice and easy.
Don't, don't.
Take your time indeed.
No rush for real.
Don't worry about it.
Just keep going.
OK.
Up.
Lift.
And right.
This way instead.
Shoot.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, gamer pain really coming in clutch right now.
Yep, yep, yep.
And let's crawl on through there.
I don't think we need that.
Put that away.
I'm just gonna guess this is where I need to go.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god, no, no, don't distract me.
Oh gosh, where, where?
Doko, doko, doko, doko.
I don't know.
Wait, I actually don't know.
I think we...
Too early, sorry.
And...
Bye Scaries!
Bye bye!
Oh what?
What did you bring me?
What did you give me?
I'm trying!
What
did she bring me?
I don't even know actually.
Oh my god.
Up or down?
Up maybe?
Up seems like a good idea.
Up seems like an optimal way to leave.
Up.
I could have gone through there maybe.
I guess not.
Through here?
This is where we came from, right?
Ok, here I go!
Up the boob, yeah.
We are just about out.
That is Gina, right?
What do you mean?
Why did you give it straight to her?
Come on!
Better him than boss maybe.
Why did you give it straight to Gina?
That guy's eyes were bugging me.
I see you found the stone for me.
Is that the stone for Machu Picchu?
You know, I had a feeling that Gan's force, that little sausage would die for his fatherland.
I hate that!
But tell me!
Did you and your sister...
Have a sweet reunion in the Malayas?
Go to hell, boss!
No, she didn't make it.
What a shame.
She didn't make it!
Giant!
Even though you are kind of a bad guy...
Why did you drop it in the middle of the walkway?
Are you kidding me?
It's a little shimmy, I know.
What are you doing?
Oh, damn!
Protection!
Thank you!
Yeah, OK, let's go.
Shoot, I'm trying to get out.
Yeah, good job, Gan.
Maybe put it up, OK.
You could have literally...
No, don't open it for them!
OK, that's good.
There you go.
Take cover!
Oh my God!
Giant stumbled like me on my way to the prison midnight.
Friendly fire!
Get their weapons.
Oh my God!
When do they run out of bullets?
Yeah!
Oh my God, finally we have a backup.
Finally!
He's with us!
Thanks!
Bye!
I'm going!
Don't die!
I'm match lady!
I'm Itoko Morning!
That applies to you too!
Big giant man!
Hold on!
Oh my God, fruit basket.
Why did you help us?
I choose the lesser evil.
Oh shoot, actually...
The enemy of your enemy, huh?
The stones cannot be used by that creature.
Oh my God, there they are.
Ah!
I tried.
Hold on.
My aim is happening.
How do I reload this thing?
Geno, you're driving!
I'm
almost out of bullets.
Oh my God!
What do you mean firing positions?
Where are they?
There they are.
Geno?
I think we did
it.
Action!
Is everybody else safe?
Oh no.
That doesn't look safe.
Geno has been captured.
All that to get captured?
What the hell?
Oh no!
No!
Who's that?
Is that Giant Man?
Oh no, it's the baddies.
No!
Her...he...it was her...
It was because of the research.
You know, not...
Spit on him!
I think if you spat on him, he would like lick it up like a lizard.
Oh damn!
Ah!
There it is!
What if all I had to do to bend her will was to threaten something of great value to her?
Like family.
This is so crazy!
Watch out Indy!
Watch out!
How can he hold on?
Indy's got such solid grip.
What do you...
What do you want me to do?
I guess follow them?
Is there a weapon?
Oh my god, there's so many guys.
How do you see me?
Oh, nice.
How does he see me?
Oh god.
Yeah, that's right.
Take his gun.
Damn.
What the fuck?
How are you still alive?
How is he still alive?
No!
I can't believe that just happened!
Lucky hat!
It's my hat!
Oh damn!
Oh my god!
What?
Maybe stealth is the way here.
If I can.
They notice me so easily.
Oh my gosh.
How?
No!
You don't notice me!
You do not notice me!
That's so unfair.
I'm just gonna keep crawling.
No.
Is that it?
French?
Holy blue.
Yeah, probably nothing.
Exactly.
Yeah, guns must be super weak in this or something, because what the hell?
I wish this guy would... Oh no, no, no.
No, please.
Leave me alone.
Just the wind.
Is he coming this way?
Oh my god.
Everybody sees me out of their peripherals like crazy.
Please, leave me alone.
I can't tell if they are coming this way or not.
Nice.
Oh shit.
Is there anyone else?
I wish I could take their uniform.
Let's go.
What?
What do you mean he got away?
Who?
Wait, they saw me?
Who saw me?
Okay.
Hop.
We continue.
I'm going.
Oh, okay.
Indy, shh, shh, shh.
Okay, I'm in the cave.
Why am I in here?
What was close?
Oh.
Gina!
Gina, I'm coming!
Gina?
Oh, Gina?
Did they like record her voice?
This is not real Gina!
This is fake!
Or...
It's fake Gina.
I got an achievement.
The Blessed Pearl.
Oh, you!
Hello.
Indy, your survival instincts.
I don't know.
The fake Gina.
Wait, a bug?
She repeats this line for the whole game now?
No way.
How much left of the game is there?
Look at him, he's so small.
Small Indiana Jones.
Little baby.
Just like a heavy rain.
Yeah!
We're leaving!
We can accomplish that area.
Let's go!
Maybe he will be more used than Gina.
Yeah, where are we going?
Oh, my hat!
We're just, you know, in the desert.
No more boats.
Oh, damn.
Okay.
Having a giant is really helpful.
Or...
Oh my god!
I love having a giant!
It's true.
It's okay if he's dead.
He should have taken his clothes.
I've killed many people.
With my fists too.
Probably.
5'11 vs.
6''.
It's true.
You know she's here?
We know nothing.
He's not gonna tell us?
Oh my god!
Angry German.
When you finally open the window...
Oh, you're not doing... You're fine.
It's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Does he see that guy's head?
It's just a rock!
Yeah, it's just a really round rock.
Shiny.
Bald.
Glistening in the moonlight.
He's Snow White?
The birds!
What?
Army of giants?
Giants?
I think I would probably do that, Indiana Jones.
I think supernatural happenings are about to start happening.
I think...
Oh, nice.
Oh, they're gonna do it for us.
Yeah, get rid of the guards!
Oh my god, what a starry night.
Beautiful.
Oh my god!
Release the giants!
Okay, cool.
I'm going too.
Here we go.
Get my friend?
Wait.
Wait, where is she?
Where is my friend?
Gina?
Who scribbled this?
Indiana Jones!
Come on man.
Wait, you were supposed to take out all the guards!
I think you missed a couple.
What's down here?
Let's try...can I go down here?
What?
I'm just...I don't know where the hell I am now.
What happened?
What?
They don't want you...Why would they let you...
They don't want you going that way apparently.
But it's just the excavation site!
Oopsie.
Anything inside here?
Oh, is this some bullets?
And my health is full.
So I guess we don't really need that.
Boss's behavior was the German dub voice of Sam from Death Stranding?
No way!
Oh, a broom.
I'm gonna sweep away the baddies.
Okay,
how do I get in?
How do I...do I open the door?
Can I do that?
There's still a lot of guys.
To the excavation site!
Oh, I see what I'm supposed to do.
Oh, they want you to jump.
Oh my god, how did anybody survive this?
My bad.
Maybe I shouldn't have...
Oh god.
Oh, I'm gonna die.
Why did the fall...
Hold on.
My hat.
This is fine actually.
Maybe they'll leave.
We got a map.
I'll take that.
I thought you guys were all being taken out.
What happened?
Oh, there's my thing.
Love the hat, Mintiana Jones.
Thank you!
Let's eat some fruit.
Or, okay, we're just throwing that on the ground.
That's fine.
Take the orange.
Take the date.
What
was that?
A letter.
Censored letter.
My dearest Gerda, I miss you terribly and hope you are doing well.
We are now stationed in... Censored.
Work is hard but incredibly exciting.
I'm not sure I'm supposed to write this, but yesterday... Oh man, spilling the tea.
Yesterday I was with...
Vos, when he found Censored.
I even got a pat on the shoulder.
That's how happy he was.
I know you won't believe me.
I didn't believe it myself at first.
This is a discovery that will shake the world.
Anyway, I can't wait to come home and take you out to a nice restaurant.
Send your mother and father my sincerest greetings.
Love, Alwin.
Indeed.
I'm being sneaky.
Apparently not sneaky enough.
Where is she again?
Where am I?
Oh, she's over there.
Maybe we can go through here.
Where are all the giants?
They were like...
Oh shit.
They were like, we are going to take out the guards and then you can run.
Hello?
Nice.
Anyway, bye.
Wait, there was something shiny there.
What's this?
A comic book.
I don't have time.
I got to go.
What's that?
A brush.
It's all we got.
It's all we got guys.
An even smaller brush.
Ok, just take the brush.
Alright, where is she?
She is...Oh, she's right there.
We are so close.
Scrub the baddies away.
Exactly.
How do I get inside?
It's a great question.
Oh my god, please, please.
No, please, please, please.
Hop, hop.
Where are they going?
Oh my god, no.
Just run.
Please, go down.
Storytrope key!
Oh, shoot.
Don't shoot, actually.
Like, don't shoot, but like, shoot me.
I mean, no, don't shoot me.
Like, dammit.
That's what I'm trying to say.
Don't like actually shoot me.
I'm going to enjoy this.
Where do I go, actually?
But I'm right here!
Please, gang!
I've done the objective.
Oh, use a bandage?
Good idea, thank you.
Who made that sound?
Oh my god, no.
Sir, please.
It was a...
Alright.
I'm going to go use this door.
That apparently...
triggers something.
Hey, Gina.
You okay?
Yeah.
Yeah, hold on.
I'm looting.
Okay.
They don't keep any...
It's a storage room and they don't have anything in here?
Okay.
I don't know how we manage that everybody, but...
Yeah, let's go.
Girl?
Yeah.
I think the giants are handling that.
Right?
The giants are going to take care of that.
They're going to take care of that, Gina.
We don't have to do anything.
Why does she have to tickle my curiosity like that?
Please, madam.
Please.
Oh dammit.
Now I want to leave.
Indy!
Yeah, she's arousing my curiosity.
I don't know.
That could mean...
Are guys lost or...
the others are dead?
Why does that look like Revolver Ocelot?
Okay.
Where is he?
Up there?
Okay.
I'm following you.
Gina, where are you going?
Okay, Gina.
Alright, Gina.
Thanks.
I'll take that, yeah.
Where are you going, girl?
I thought we were going to go to where Vos is?
So literally, just go up there.
Okay, got it.
We can totally do this.
A gun.
There's so many guys.
There's so many guys, Gina.
Don't get caught.
Madam.
Shoot.
Oh.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Nobody saw anything.
Are they?
Who?
Oh, that person?
Don't worry about them.
Shut up, Gina.
No, please.
Yeah.
Get him, Gina.
I'm trying to run.
Nice.
Oh god, there's more.
Oh my god, I'm so dead.
I'm eating bullets.
I'm so dead.
Why are there three of you?
Please go away.
Gina, are you okay?
Oh.
Oh man.
Okay, maybe another strat.
Yeah, go in here.
Grab this.
Yeah.
And we'll go.
But I like having my...
No.
I like having the mallet at the beginning at least.
Maybe we take out this person here first.
Where are they?
Oh, there they are.
I think if I go around and I take them out...
Then it could be okay.
They noticed me too well.
You know what I mean?
Stop goofing around.
They noticed me.
And then...
I can't do like the sneak...
Hello.
Yeah, Gina!
Get his ass!
I'm so dead.
Just die.
Gina!
Metal Gear Solid Addict.
By the way, hey, hey, hey!
I have always, 100% always been open about the fact that I hate stealth games, okay?
Don't put the...Don't mix Metal Gear in here.
I hate stealth.
Oh, but she plays Metal Gear Solid.
I play poorly.
Indiana Jones needs to think of the box.
How do we...
Maybe I go this way instead.
Seems to be a better way around.
Maybe.
Yeah.
Nice.
Nice, nice.
Okay.
And this guy too.
Let's take him out.
Let's get him.
Let's get his...
Let's get his ass.
Why are you so flimsy?
I did see back there was a...
Was a...
Stop wanting me to take a picture.
There was a...
What's it called?
A shovel.
I could try and grab it.
Before anyone notices maybe.
Oh shoot.
Nevermind, nevermind.
I'm trying.
Oh my god, that guy is about to see us.
Okay, it's going down.
Nice.
Okay.
Yeah, nothing to worry about.
Nothing to worry about, nothing to worry about, nothing to worry about.
Okay.
You can only melee with a gun once it's out of bullets.
At least that has been my experience.
So...
She doesn't know you can melee with a gun only when it's out of bullets.
Not true?
What?
Then why?
Oh my god.
Where is his gun?
What do you press?
You can swap it?
Okay, now that I didn't know.
Let's see.
Carry.
How do I swap?
With X?
Oh my god.
Huge!
Now that I didn't know.
Bless you.
Why are you one hit?
Why is that one hit usually?
Really?
If I X?
They do?
Oh my god, where?
When?
Where?
Where do they see me?
Yeah, they're everywhere Gina.
God damn it.
Okay, this is the one.
Alright, alright.
Oh my god!
Okay, we got him.
Very good.
Okay, stronger one.
Alright.
So far, not so bad.
I wish it would save though, because that would be really dandy.
Okay.
Surprise.
Take that.
What's this?
Excavation plans.
Okay.
Take that.
No, switch.
Fuel.
Okay, there we go.
And the reason I'm switching is because I'm blocking it, but the weapons are about to break.
So that's why I'm like going through and switching, but you can't really see because I'm blocking it.
How do I get up there?
Gina, girl.
The durability.
Maybe up here?
This way?
No?
Am I not in a good place?
No.
I can't see anything.
This thing is so huge.
Did
I go to the wrong place?
God, I wish it would save.
I don't want to have to do all of this over again.
Madam?
Where are you going?
I don't know where to go.
Can you save automatically?
I'm not sure.
Let's see.
Nope.
Up the stairs?
Stairs.
This way?
Are there stairs over here?
What do you think of weapons durability mechanics?
Oh my god, there's a guy there.
They're fine.
Again?
I think some things... I don't like how these are... If you do the sneak attack, it's...
It's like two hits.
But it is what it is.
I am lost.
The farm is on the left side.
Which left?
I'm so lost.
Also, how did we get seen from over here?
I don't know.
So we have to go all the way actually to the other side.
Okay, we go over here.
Where all the bright lights and people are.
That's really great.
I love that.
That's so awesome.
That's so great.
That's just so awesome.
Oh my god.
No, you didn't.
I wish I could bait him over here.
Oh, wait, he's coming.
I think.
I had no idea how to use the repair kits.
Is that for the weapons?
I guess that makes sense.
I have some.
Okay, I think I'm just gonna have to do it.
I don't know.
Oh shit.
No!
You bastard!
You bitch!
Fuck you!
You suck!
You fucking bitch!
This
is not a smirking moment!
Indiana Jones!
Oh my god.
Gina!
Gina?
Maybe?
Oh,
it's saved here.
Interesting.
Okay.
That could be worse.
I guess we at least keep the stuff that we got.
I wish I had a little bottle that I could throw and distract him and have him walk over.
That's what I need.
I need to...
It's this guy!
I hope... I hope you... I hope you miss Christmas with your family every year for the rest of your life.
Can you throw a gun?
Let's try it.
Don't shoot.
Yeah, there we go.
Gina!
Gina.
Okay, Gina.
We need this guy to turn around.
Please.
Okay, he's gone.
Well, not gone, but you know.
Bit of a lag.
Oh, Gina.
He's gonna see us.
Maybe not.
Goodbye weapon.
Oh my god.
Push her up.
Gina, you're so possessed.
I don't like you anymore.
Okay.
You okay?
Good work.
Yeah, shut up, please.
Oh my god, you're so loud.
What about me?
Oh my god.
This is a stealth mission.
Please.
Are there any other guys?
Oh, it's saved.
Oh, hallelujah.
It's saved.
Is there a guy up here?
Did I see a little question mark?
No?
Okay.
What else is...
This is where...
What am I taking a picture of?
The camp?
That guy.
Right there.
Oh, I wish I could snipe him.
Oh, I hate you with every... I don't have any bones in my body.
I hate you!
Okay.
Look at that.
The giants did this.
I don't think we need to be sneaky anymore, do we?
Wait!
Wait, Gina!
Gina, I think there's a...
Okay.
Bang,
bang, bang.
And here we go.
Bye!
Very good.
Wow.
Reverse MGS1 intro.
You think there will be more nachos downstairs?
I'm so tired.
Nineveh document.
Summary of translation of Stele S-12.
The translation of the Sumerian carvings found in Stele S-12 in Antechamber F revealed interesting leads.
The ancient temple later built by the Ziggurat of Ur was raised by the descendants of those who survived.
One of them traveled north with a sacred gift where they founded what would become the city of Nineveh.
Nineveh.
Perhaps this gift can still be found within the ruins of the ancient city.
I will write a report to S.S.
Hoptampt, requesting this lead to be followed up after Operation Great Circle is complete.
There may be untold treasures to be found in Nineveh, or untold powers.
From Boss Emmerich.
Descendants of those who survived.
Wait, what's that though?
We can take the lift.
I think she's already working on it.
Emmerich.
How did those other guys get up then if there's no power?
Do they also climb?
Please no spoilers even about what the end is.
Please no spoilers.
Especially if you tag me.
Come on.
Oh my gosh.
Good thing I didn't eat the other...
The other donut the other day.
Wait, no power still?
I guess, I mean...
Generator where?
Where did you see a generator?
I hear it.
Up that?
There?
That?
Can I make this?
I got it.
Spoiler, the game ends at the end.
Just hit it.
One, two.
There we go.
How do I...
Oh my gosh, can you imagine?
It's like alright.
Keep going down baby.
Uh...
Oh...
I will?
How do I get out of here?
We made it down like two steps.
I can?
Oh my god.
Um, yeah.
Nice.
What is blocking?
Do I just keep going down?
What?
Probably was a more graceful way to do that.
But I'm not very grace... Grace is not my middle name.
I'm working on it.
We died.
Thanks for the diamonds.
Yeah, I know.
Keep going.
Down.
Oh no!
Oh no.
Yeah.
Oh, no we're not.
We're like besties.
Love that guy.
Okay.
There's stuff around here.
What's this?
Oh, Gina?
I guess we're opening this.
Oh, I didn't get to explore the other.
My bad.
What is this?
Is that what I think it is?
What do you think it is?
It's real?
That's what I thought, but...
Oh no.
I don't know.
Uh oh.
He's going to ride the boat through time.
Be the great...
Now what?
What?
Oh my god, no.
Please, I need Gina.
I need your fists.
Just in case.
Please.
Ta-da!
No, don't go down yet Indy.
I didn't get to explore the other area.
Let me back up!
Hold on.
Get to the tent.
Okay, hold on.
But before that...
Damn, no wonder the giants didn't make it past anywhere.
There's so many...
There's so many guys in here.
Secret vault.
Four stars.
What the hell?
Did they make this?
Arks and all gear.
Indy found both arks.
I know, right?
What is that?
They had a lot to say apparently.
Hold on, I want to make sure that I've...
Look, we got button then.
What was this?
One-handed firearms deal more damage.
Nice.
I think that's the only one we have.
Yeah, unfortunately.
Oh well.
Okay.
This is so sick!
Oops, there we go.
I'm just slow.
Yeah, I have a ton of points.
I wish I had more books.
But I'm also poor.
There's also a pier.
Like, it looks like I can climb up here.
So I kind of want to do that real quick to see...
Just...
What's...
Nevermind.
Indy's arms are like a T-Rex.
Teeny tiny little baby.
Okay, nevermind.
I have explored everything apparently.
I thought there may be...
He looks so peaceful.
Wake up, giant.
I'm gonna be like that pig in that video.
Oh, peaceful.
I hope they're not dead.
Do you think they're asleep or dead?
Okay, here we go!
This game...
This game knows how to do really great visuals.
Like...
Really great, like...
Wow...
Is it moving?
Or am I crazy?
Like, is it kind of like...
No, I don't think so.
I thought it might be...
I'm crazy?
Maybe.
To the tent!
Oh, there's a hammer right there.
There's a mallet.
Don't see me.
Oh my god, there's so many guys around.
Wait!
What the?
Oh, he's chilling?
Let's take a little break.
Wow!
It's huge!
Look, there's even guys patrolling through there.
This isn't gonna be very fun now, is it?
Is that the giant or is that...
I can't tell.
Who are you?
Oh, you're not the giant.
Oh, you do have guns in here.
I don't like that.
Don't do that.
No, shoot the kill!
Shoot the kill!
Where did you come from?
Oh my god.
I'm getting ganged up on.
This isn't fair.
My grandma hits harder.
I don't think we're making it out of this one, but...
Can I have my hat?
They're spawn camping me.
We look so smug for the situation that we're in.
It's quite dire.
Okay.
Take that.
Nice.
Cool.
Oh, okay.
I'm gonna heal.
In case this actually works out.
Where did my weapon go?
Is that the weapon I just grabbed?
What was that?
Okay.
I thought I grabbed something better than that.
Alright.
Let's continue onward.
La la la.
This might be a better way anyway.
Nice.
Stealth 100.
Stealth 99.
Okay.
I wish I could see through here.
Go up.
I don't think...
Oh, I can.
Oh my gosh.
How did you see that?
Indy, please.
Indy.
Oh my god.
How did you see that?
Oh look, there's a ton of them too.
I wonder if I could just start throwing...
I could just start throwing hammers at everybody.
We're so close.
It's right there.
I need this guy to go away.
Do you think he'll notice if I throw a hammer at him?
He's kinda far now though, right?
There's like so... It's like all in the light so I know I'm gonna get seen.
And he's looking straight where we need to go.
And he took out his weapon for what?
Okay, this might be our chance.
Oh my gosh.
I think this is our chance.
Just go, go, go.
Nothing.
Who's seeing me?
No one.
Yeah, exactly.
Nice.
Locus!
I thought you were by the campfire.
I saw another...
Bald man.
Oh my God.
Why do you have that?
You found the Ark of the Covenant, yes, but I found Noah's Ark.
What makes you think it's the real one?
Come on, Indiana.
Please, isn't it time we dispense with the patterns already?
Why don't you and I have a meeting of the minds instead?
We're gonna have a nerd-off.
What if it starts asking me questions of like smarts?
What I'd like to do is put the guns down.
I have it like that too.
I'll knock your teeth out.
Fair warning.
I have mastered the lethal Japanese hand-to-hand combat art.
CQC?
Karate!
Well, I can just have my gacha with you.
Dareweave!
What do you know about the myth of the Great Flood?
He got one of every animal.
Girl and boy.
I played that one racing game.
Karate!
Teh!
I know, Vos is so funny.
We love a funny villain, right?
Roberto, welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
I know one you haven't heard of.
Tell me a bedtime story.
Come, come.
I don't think this is...I don't think...I don't think this is a...
Yeah, you should grab that.
Oh!
An Among Us!
They were showing us the Among Us.
From an excavation in North Africa.
Ah!
I love when the baddies just say...
Everything...
Their whole plan, you know?
Dark...
Seventeen?
We only have two.
Seventeen stones, seventeen words.
Each stone connected to one of the locations of the Great Circle.
Noir used the stones to gather animals from around the world.
And then, after the flood was over...
To repopulate the earth.
And the stones were left hidden at each of the Great Circle's sites...
You know, fish were so happy during that time.
They were like...
Yeah!
Our time has come!
Golden Age of Fish.
They could have literally taken over if they were smarter.
Keep them what?
Yeah, that's kind of what that guy's been really trying to do for...
What?
I'm Indy.
I mean...
If you have found this, you probably would have been looking for it too.
Let's be honest.
Is that her sister?
Oh, shit.
Ma'am?
Gina?!
Gina, do it.
What a preposterous woman.
And now she's dead.
Gina, do it.
Gina, do it!
We should have just done it.
Gina, do it.
Oh!
Oh, no!
Gina, you should have checked!
Like a rat.
No!
Oh my...
Boss, listen to me.
You're messing with powers beyond your control.
No!
My whip!
Oh my god.
He rubs the lotion on his skin.
Toxic yaoi.
How is this thing still intact?
How is it not falling apart?
Yeah, it's a big ol' boat.
Lake Hamar?
Boss, an Indy fan?
Wants to collab?
With his Oshi?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cool shy.
I know, right?
This game is really good with the cinematics.
He's cooking it with him!
I'm calm.
I'm cool.
I'm as cool as a cucumber.
I spoke too soon, Indiana Jones.
Oh...
Does he know the words?
Does he know the words to say?
I like how they're all so colorful.
They look like forbidden candy.
I want to eat the stones.
In front of my house!
And then finally, Indiana Jones will be yours.
Oh, come on.
Okay.
Poor Locus.
Yaoi whip.
That's the yaoi whip.
Anyone who touches it becomes a...
He's so corny.
I'm kind of obsessed.
So funny.
Oh, Locus.
Guys, I think things are about to get a little... a little freaky.
I think things are about to get a little freaky.
Oh, he's saying it.
He doesn't know the words.
Oh, sorry.
I'm in a cutscene.
What are you... Excuse me.
Of course I'm not using my controller.
Sorry everybody.
Maybe I need to be like looking around that you expect me to?
I don't know.
Ears of a hawk.
Excuse me.
Oh no.
He's freaking out.
He's losing it.
Nice.
Oh my God.
Flat Earth time.
Yeah!
Oh no!
We're about to get squished!
Squished.
He can't read.
He got one wrong.
What's so funny Indiana Jones?
I don't know.
What is he... Did he just start like another flood?
Oh boy.
Guys, it's getting freaky!
Oh my God!
You said you knew what you were doing!
Kuwabara!
Yeah, do Locus first.
What do you mean?
Lies!
He summoned Heavy Rain.
He's so crazy.
Yeah, get his ass!
Oh, what am I supposed to do?
Yeah, give me...help me.
Oh no no!
Hello!
Oh my God!
Oh my God, he's so nimble.
He's nimble.
That's not fair.
That's so unfair.
Oh, he's got really long legs.
How the hell...
I don't remember how to dodge.
Oh shoot.
I don't remember.
Ok,
if you get too far from him...
Oh my God, he's so
nimble.
How is it...hold on.
What was the...and you don't have your hat, so you don't have the lucky hat anymore.
What was the controls to sidestep and everything?
You guys remember?
A and move?
Ok, thank you.
Yeah, LB is blocked.
I do know that, but you still take damage, you know.
Oh my God, but I'm trying to...I'm trying!
Hold on!
Oh!
Oh gosh!
Yes, idiot!
Where are you going, eh baby?
Oh ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I thought I would be able to...
Oh my God!
I don't have any of my items.
Oh shit!
I was doing so well.
I was doing alright for a second.
His karate is crazy.
That chop did not hit.
I know, what's my hitbox, eh?
Where's my hitbox anyway?
I'm not going anywhere.
Yeah, that's right.
Circle strafe, circle strafe, circle strafe, circle strafe, circle strafe...
Oh, I have none.
Yeah, dummy!
Circle strafe!
Oh my God, I'm trapped, I'm trapped on something.
Oh my God.
No!
Oh, I dodged that though.
Such bullshit.
I'm just building up my... what's it called?
My stamina.
Yeah, yeah.
You're obsessed?
Gosh, this is just like fighting on top of a Metal Gear, isn't it?
I don't think that does damage, so it's not so bad.
You little bastard!
I thought I was supposed to go help Gina, but she's got it handled, I think.
But you're in love?
Oh no.
My controller is like doing heartbeats.
Oh my god!
This guy is literally gonna take me down with him!
What is this?
Wait, are we gonna have to fight here?
Please god no.
This is... no.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna... I have 1 HP and a dream baby!
Karate!
Maybe.
I'm like trying to block, but...
I still take damage.
I think I just have to last.
Help Gina please!
Yeah, kick him.
I'm blocking.
I'm punching.
I'm kicking.
I'm blocking.
This is so stupid.
Help me!
Thank you.
Atonement.
Grab my whip!
Grab my whip please!
Uh oh.
Locus.
Yes!
I was stuck on this for 30 minutes and he did a second try.
I told you.
When yaoi on the brain, anything is possible.
Get swept up.
Honestly the side-sweep, like the circle around him while I'm punching, I think did well.
Oh my god.
Locus!
What is he trying to do?
What is this?
Oh my god, give up!
Give up!
You are so annoying!
Glad you like it.
Everyone is always telling me I'm so ugly!
Locus you got this!
Karate.
Karate!
Oh
my god, I think that's finally it for him baby!
Yay!
Reposo!
Indiana Jones!
Locus!
Off boat now!
Ok.
Off boat now.
Ok we trust you!
We trust you Locus!
You don't know how to swim!
Uh oh.
She gonna learn.
Oh my god.
Oh it's teleporting somewhere!
Where?
Isekai!
Locus!
You did well buddy!
You did well!
Locus going into the light!
07.
07 for Locus.
What the hell was that?
Please be a world with cute anime girls.
I'm sure it is.
Locus.
He sacrificed himself!
Time I got reincarnated in another world with Noah's Ark.
So I guess like the wheel would like...
You could steer it to activate the portal?
I don't really understand.
I don't really understand what's going on.
If it loves you it will come back.
You let it go and if it loves you it will return.
Is that not the boat?
Thank you.
So do you want to stick around for a little while?
I got some friends.
You could show us the sights.
There's a war coming.
And I have a hell of a story to tell.
And I think you will be too busy chasing the past.
Oh that's what his last girl said too.
I don't know.
I think I could make room for other things.
Well not me.
Not now.
Too much is at stake.
Adios Rambo.
Adios.
Not even a kiss.
Not even on the cheek.
We fumbled hard guys.
Josh!
Laura.
Ah!
She heard you.
Lude.
Is this really it?
Is this really the end of the game?
Indiana Jones and the Great Circle!
What the hell was
the...
It was the steering wheel.
OK.
I expected something greater.
I don't know.
The Great Circle was Indy's relationship.
No, it was a... I think it should have been named like the Mysterious Circle because what the hell.
Teleporting arc was kinda cool.
Pretty cool yeah.
I wonder where it went.
I'm so curious.
I could never be Indiana Jones.
I would have never jumped.
I would have gone with him.
Where did it go?
The Great Circle is the people we fought along the way.
This music is great.
Gran Tinto that was fine and now another game down on your resolution list.
Yeah!
The Great Circle is the friends we made along the way.
I wonder if there is an after credits thing.
Indiana Jones though.
He doesn't always really figure out what a thing is.
Just something crazy.
Teleportation.
We had the Calimao.
We had the Ark.
So crazy.
You need to tell me.
You built a time machine out of a bone.
That's like soul.
That's basically Doraemon.
Or Doctor Who.
Congrats Mito.
By the way, the secret ball you saw was a post game puzzle that takes all 50 of the Among Us to complete.
Wait, secret ball.
You get a cutscene after that.
You might want to look it up.
Interesting.
Did Indy ever get his job back?
Yeah!
We have so many...
I feel like there has to be a...
Post credits scene, right?
How many Among Us did I get?
50 of them.
That's insane.
And it has a planned DLC.
Great Circle was the last boss track.
So true.
Fantastic movie.
Thanks for sharing it with us.
Cannot believe they actually made a good licensed game in current year.
True, right?
It feels so true to the original.
Which is nice.
Troy Baker!
He did such a great job as Indiana Jones.
He sounded more like Harrison Ford than Harrison Ford sometimes.
It was too good.
It was too good of an impression.
Like insane.
Tony Todd?
Who did he voice?
Did people say?
Did he pass away?
I'll look him up.
Hold on.
Oh, Locus!
Was this one of his last works then?
I wonder.
He passed away right before the game countdown.
Second to last.
Everyone did so amazing though.
The game is scuffed though to where it's not a problem.
It's funny.
But...
Now that you won, you can get Vos' Mogas.
Right!
We weren't able to get that.
That was there.
It's funny scuffed.
Overall, I did really enjoy the game.
Like I said, I think it was...
I'm so shocked at how much is packed into this game.
Truly.
So much.
Well done, Indiana!
If you ever want to play the older Indiana Jones games, they're all on Steam and pretty good.
I heard they're not very good though.
I heard the Lego ones weren't bad.
Hope you'll try playing Tomb Raider after this.
Oh, I hate Tomb Raider controls, RedWolf.
Like classic Tomb Raider controls are so...
I tried playing the demo and it's so bad.
The Lego games are fun.
No,
the new ones?
How about Uncharted?
I have Uncharted.
I got gifted Uncharted, so...
I have already talked about wanting to play that.
Eventually, yeah, I would like to play it.
I know this is kind of unrelated too, but I also really want to play Red Dead Redemption.
There has to be a post-credits scene.
I swear.
So many games.
So many games I want to play.
But we have time, so it's all good.
It's got whips and cowboy hats, I know.
Indiana Jones and the Emperor's Tomb is good.
It's a long game, I know.
That's okay though.
I've done long games before.
Can't wait for MGS4.
Me too.
I love how the ending of this is very MGS4.
Indy was my childhood hero.
This game was so faithful to the source material.
Thanks for taking us on this adventure.
I'm glad you guys liked it.
It's funny, I only watched Indiana Jones for the first time in recent years.
So, my love for Indiana Jones is very fresh.
It's very fresh.
It's very like...
So cool.
Like Metal Gear.
Exactly!
Would you recommend this game?
I think so.
I think this game has...
And also it has many ways you can play it.
Like you can go full stealth.
Or you can go full action.
It's kind of... I think it has a great play style.
I would say the NPC are just dumb enough for it.
Not frustrating.
You know, it's like they're...
It's not gonna be like so...
So like...
Oh my god, I have to do this over and over and over again.
And it's so horrible because this and that.
Like they're just dumb enough where it's like...
Okay, I can get through this.
I love the fist fights.
Yeah, they're fun.
So fun, so fun.
Why are you guys saying Persona 5?
There has to be something post-credits, but these are the longest credits ever.
It's like waiting...
So I watched Transformers 1 again last night.
Just because I felt like it.
And my favorite scene in the whole movie is...
Or rather, not my favorite scene, but probably my favorite visuals in the whole movie are the post-credits scenes.
But the credits are so long.
And then you have to listen to that song and it's just like...
I'm feeling good.
Optimus.
Something something.
Megatron.
Credits are 36 minutes long?
Wait, actually?
No, you guys are...
You can skip the credits?
Yippee!
Thanks to everyone who worked on the game.
Oh,
sorry.
Wait, but like...
What about our job?
How many Among Us do I have?
Among Us...
Is it then a puzzle even?
And then it's a puzzle?
No way.
Oh my...
Oh my god.
Oh, I get it though.
Wait, maybe I don't get it.
I thought that everything...
If you stuck one in, all the ones to the side would come out.
But this one stopped here.
And stopped here.
I don't even know how many Among Us I have.
Wait, so if I go back to give losses...
Are they still there?
I see the vision.
Are all the baddies gone?
No.
It's not all empty now.
Took me over 40 minutes by the way.
Oh my god.
Uh...
What if they know that I killed their boss?
Oh.
I'm walking on through.
Everybody is still down though.
That's kind of insane.
No, they don't care that I killed their boss.
You don't wonder what that was.
You don't care.
I think once you beat them, they won't respawn.
I think that's the case too.
Which is very nice.
Who is seeing me?
Through the wall?
Excuse me?
Hawkeye vision?
Over here?
The Ark is back.
It's like we never did anything.
That guy is new.
Definitely did not see him before.
You are not climbing up here, are you?
Hammer time.
I beat the game, so why not?
Everybody in the camp has been alerted.
Hi.
Oh, come on.
Shovel.
Hey, this isn't funny.
Yeah, this isn't funny.
Da da da!
I got it.
I don't know if that counted.
Anyway, let's...
Let's quit the game.
Yeah.
I want to see that post-game puzzle sequence.
Give me a second to switch.
My monitors might get all funky with this.
Just a second, because I have to switch my display.
Give me a second.
Please don't get funky.
It's going to get funky!
It got less funky than I thought.
That's great.
Yippee!
Okay, hold on, one second.
One second, everybody.
One moment, and then we shall watch that post-game...
Together, post-game...
Content.
Okay, what am I searching?
Oh, Indiana Jones Great Circle.
Secret ending.
I have to find one of a person that's not talking.
So, I'm going to turn off the volume real quick for you guys.
This one's only 51 seconds.
I'm going to do...
Oh, I think these ones show how the puzzle works.
So, hold on.
If we want to see that.
No, I think I'm okay.
Here, we'll start it at like...
Partially through the puzzle.
Okay, hold on, hold on.
One moment, please.
Let me...
Window capture.
And capture Indiana Jones.
And let me...
Let me make it small.
Oh, wait.
Small, small, small, small.
Small, small, small.
Wait a second.
Why is it doing that?
That's weird.
That should be good.
That should work.
This is... Oh, hold on.
Let me get the top.
This is from...
YouTube channel Wicked.
So, thanks Wicked.
They solved the whole puzzle.
So, we're just going to watch the end of the puzzle and then I guess the...
The secret cutscene.
Oh, hold on.
I'm going to shut this off.
There we go.
And do...
This.
Perfect timing.
Wow, I just skipped to that part.
The Amogus were so powerful.
We didn't even know.
Oh my gosh.
It's the real Great Circle.
Maybe.
It went to...
It also went to the Himalayas?
Are those footsteps?
Is that it?
Locus lives?
Sounds like Harry Potter.
Locus is alive!
Okay.
Fascinating.
Well guys, we did it!
I'm...
Yay, he can go back.
What does he do from now on?
What do you do from here?
I guess maybe he will go hide the little stones again.
Maybe he will go hide the stones.
That's what he does with his life.
I wonder what the DLC will be like too.
That was fun!
Thank you guys for this grand Indie adventure.
Wait, let me see.
He's looking at me.
Hi Indie!
He's like, why do you have my whip?
Hi!
Hi Indiana Jones!
Wait, hold on.
I can make this a little more immersive.
Let's change the lighting a little bit.
One second.
Let's see.
No, not pink.
Wait.
This.
There we go.
Indiana Jones!
Maybe a little darker.
Indiana Jones, look at me.
I'm going to go fight those guys and I'm going to go get the Among Us and then we're going to go to the Himalayas.
Did he have like a...
Oh, I'm standing on this guy!
Sorry.
Here, I'll stand back here.
Now it looks like we're about to have a...
Like some sort of...
We're about to have a battle.
Boo!
Yeah, we're going to have a fist fight.
My fists are already up.
Boo!
Yeah, come at me, Indiana Jones!
Come at me!
I stole your whole look!
I stole your whip!
I stole your hat!
Yeah, you want to come at me?
Look, I'm going to make my hat much bigger than yours.
What do you think about that, Indiana Jones?
Yeah!
Indiana Jones, what do you think about that?
The legendary 30-gallon hat.
This hat ain't big enough for the two of us.
Well guys, yeah, I do know karate!
This is so much fun!
I'm glad that we could go on this adventure together.
I thought I had much more of the game left to do, so...
I started so early because I was like, OK, we're going to go so long!
But it ended up not being that much longer, so that's great.
Now I can go eat some dinner!
Thank you guys!
Karaage?
Yeah, I'm going to have some... No, I don't have any karaage, unfortunately.
I don't know what to have for dinner.
I don't know.
Anyway!
Otsumita!
Bone apple teeth, thank you.
I'll see you guys later.
Bye!
Itadakimasu!
Bye bye!
I'm going to go handle Indiana Jones now.
I'm going to take him down.
Bye bye!